you know breaking a habit is never easy
but fume can help you create better
habits can't you yes he can it might be
a sh I've not checked but not everything
in a habit is wrong so instead of making
a big uncomfortable change why not just
remove the bad from your habit fume is
an Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that instead of
vapor fume uses flavored Air instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses delicious flavors your fume comes
with an adjustable airflow dial and is
designed with movable parts and for
fidgeting giving your fingers a lot to
do which is helpful for de-stressing and
anxiety while sprinking your habit and
all you do
is breathe it in like that when you
inhale it like that you get a lovely
after Taste of flavors I'm using the
orange vanilla which is my favorite
highly recommend it it's very weighty
well crafted lovely uh wooden handle
there and perfectly balanced to fidget
with so stopping something is hard but
switching the fume is easy and enjoyable
and fume has served over
150,000 people with thousands of success
stories and there's no reason why that
can't be you so head to
tume.to yfu m.com and use the code true
that's t a all block capitals all one
word at checkout and you'll get 10% off
when you buy the journey pack today but
for now enjoy the
[Music]
video he's a Content King do you know
that
true you're going to decide that are you
what the [__] wrong with you know how
they play I want to
[Applause]
out all right welcome back to the true
Jordy podcast today's guest is the UFC
heavyweight champion of the world Tom
aspal thanks for coming on mate thank
you don't forget to say interim people
get very upset about that if you don't
say that so yeah I'm here mate finally
uh we know that we've been texting back
and forward for quite a while so it's
the logistics haven't worked out but
yeah we're finally here now appreciate
it appreciate I've been tting questions
uh what would it take for a UFC fight
out of finger you oh not much
apparently I love that you know actually
was the most human moment where you're
trying to ban back and forth with
someone who's doing this all the time
and it gets taken out of context and
immediately everyone's like oh he's a
misogynist or whatever the daily mail or
right what was that like just to go um
cuz you're not long on the Belt well you
got to watch what you're saying mate
when you when you going up in levels and
you know I'm a normal guy I've not had
no media training nothing like that see
it's it's different like with a bit of
context behind it me me and Nina know
each other of course we were talking off
camera about she gets like loads of mad
questions on Instagram and stuff and
people are asking has she been having
sex with Dana white people have been
asking has she been fingered by UFC
fighters and and all that and then she
asked me something about she M she asked
me loads of weird questions that's her
no one cares about that yeah that's her
thing she can ask me 20 minutes
literally 20 minutes of weird questions
I throw one back at her just for a laugh
mate just cuz I know Nina and I knew she
w't take it in a bad way but man you got
to watch what you're saying I guess
sometimes you [__] swing and Miss
don't you that was such a lesson for you
it was it was it was but I've seen it a
lot since as well like even with the
situation like I'm sure we're going to
go into this throughout the podcast but
I'm in a bit of a sticky situation now
with the politics of the UFC kind of
thing who am I going to fight next and
should I defend an interim should I
fight Stipe should I fight JN Jones what
should should I wait it out man doesn't
matter what you say people are always
going to [__] jump on you you know
more than me you're famous than I am
people are going to jump on you and be
like you said the wrong thing yeah like
if I want to fight stpe no you shouldn't
fight Stipe and it's the same with
anything mate you just got to you can
never like idiot proof everything that
you say so I'm learning mate I'm
learning on the job I think that part of
the problem is when you come into it
looking like a sort of a squeaky clean
guy you you had a very wholesome image
and you're very down to earth that
you're just there to make any little
mistake wrong whereas someone like a
Sean Strickland is almost unconsolable
because they know he doesn't give a [__]
but they think you know you do yeah
definitely M like when you see like I
had to
explain uh to like some f some female
family members who are not into MMA and
they just see a headline of like MMA
champion sexually abuses female reporter
and I'm just like what the [__] [__]
watch the full interview when you see a
10-second clipmate and it goes like and
I ask her the question have you been
figing out yeah it looks pretty bad
granted like I I hold my hands up that
doesn't look good but if you watch the
full interview mate when she's she asked
me all kinds of stuff and I think it's
hilarious like her stuff I absolutely
love who Nina is what she's all about
and what she brings to light the UFC
because a lot of the time mate as a
fighter myself especially fight weeks
especially big fight weeks you you you
ask the same questions it's boring so I
appreciate Nina for what she is and I
appreciate appreciate her Channel but
like when he ask one back it's like
[__] know this guy's some kind of
[__] sex addict so I don't know some
kind of weirdo but it wasn't like that
mate it wasn't like that at all she she
played it perfectly as well she very
much like a Ricky ja character I was
like uh she's great knew what she was
she's great she's great Nina's great
I've not got a bad word to say about her
so so going back early on to your UFC
career it was very apparent very quickly
you're a different Beast to a lot of
these other heavyweights uh this
combination of like if if you were look
at other UFC fighters You' be like he's
kind of got the power of Francis but the
speed of gone it's a freaky combination
at what point Did you sort of start to
Twig in your life even I'm Different to
these other
cats uh it's a great
question I'm still not sure and I think
that
unsureness gives me an edge if that if
that makes any kind of sense I think
that I'm like even now I've just won in
my opinion I've just beat the scariest
guy in the UFC in a
minute but I'm still nowhere near
satisfied and I'm still aware that my
sport is [__] absolutely crazy
especially at the heavyweight division
like in my opinion MMA is like the most
unpredictable sport in the world and at
heavyweights even more so and I just
don't rest on me being better than
everybody like I know that skill goes a
long way I don't know I think I think I
know I'm jumping around a little bit
here but
I think that my dad installed young to
me like because I've been training with
my dad since I was six years old
that this is like a sport do you know
what I mean you you have to treat it for
what it is and what it is to me is it's
just a sport I don't look at it like a
fight or I've got beef for anyone or
anything like that like I literally try
and hit them and don't let them hit me
and that that's kind of the root like
it's almost like a bit of it's almost
like a game of tag for me that's how I
treat it I don't treat it anything more
I try not to look at it too deeply and
try and get in like a beast mode or a
warrior SP like it's I'm just doing a
sport and that's the way I treat it
you're a thinking man's fight I me um I
don't know about that but I just trying
to see it for what it is like even to my
low level of sparring that I've done I
felt the same way like I never felt like
I wanted to take this guy's head off and
I think that that's the cleverest way to
play it because in a in a heavyweight
competition you know the more you're
thinking with aggression and and and I
am going to bully you um you're sort of
playing into the the G side of it and
especially in the heavy WTH cuz you just
really shouldn't be gambling well I
think as a big guy um so big guys like
our size they come into the gym they're
20 years old or whatever and they don't
they're not used to getting hit and when
they do get hit it's like [__] hell
I've just been hit off this guy I'm
twice as big as I need to get him back
and they don't know how to deal with it
whereas me I've been doing martial arts
since I was 6 years old I started as a
small it's like I started training
adults classes well it wasn't like
adults classes when I first started MMA
there wasn't kids class it didn't exist
at the time it wasn't the the sport
wasn't developed enough to have like 30
kids on the M training like when I was
10 years old I was training with 20
adults who were in the 40s you know what
I mean so um I'm I've been used to like
being the nail so to speak like I've
took a lot of shots and I've been in a
lot of bad spots from being really young
so I just see it see it like that
whereas big guys come in the gym and
they don't need as much technique as as
other guys because the they're big
they're [__] massive like they're
just squisher and cuz I started off
really young I've got that massive
advantage on people is that I'm used to
taking the shots and when I do get hit
it doesn't I'm not flustered by it do
you know what I mean when I'm in a bad
position I'm not flustered by it I'm
just like right I'll just wait my turn
I'll get my get myself together and I'll
wait my moment that's probably why you
move so well because um with biger dudes
movement is the hardest thing right you
know the footwork and stuff like that it
comes a lot harder to the biger place
which is why people like yourself Fury
and Etc they're the anomalies but
because you've been getting your body
used to doing the same thing as you
you've grown into this [__] massive
dude you now can carry those techniques
from being a smaller guy upward um you
know in terms of like weightlifting and
speed training and stuff like that are
you tracking all your numbers or are you
sort of not really bothered about that
um to a degree like I know where I'm at
to a degree but I'm not like I lifted
this last week I got to lift this this
week do you know what I mean it's like
yeah um yeah but just just to touch on
that a little bit I've had some really
good coaches as well like over the years
I've trained a lot of different places
and
um the speed thing has always been
encouraged by everybody I've always been
fast and and I think I'm not I'm
genetically fast anyway I don't think
you can definitely improve that to a
degree but I think I'm genetically fast
anyway um but that's something I always
wanted to to keep up with the smaller
guys I never wanted to let like Let My
Size Hold Me Back CU you see a lot of
big guys who just they're just lazy
bastards mate and I don't want to be
that guy but uh yeah I always try and do
it even like lifting weights I'm not
lifting weights like bodybuilder I'm not
doing all time on detention stuff like
I'm lifting the weights as fast as I can
for short amount of reps and and putting
it down yeah yeah well it [__] shows
doesn't it um in terms of for me the
fight that made me go all right this guy
is this is something serious we've got a
real talent in the UK here was the arosi
fight I think you showed so many
different aspects of your game in that
fight of um not only were you you know
and oroski is Legend really I mean what
a guy to still that length of career and
you put it on him didn't quite get him
out there immediately had have your
composure and then the takeown and the
submission I was like okay you've just
you played with him and you were like
you were enjoying it yeah I mean alosi
for me he is literally one of the
reasons I got into MMA the UFC came to
Manchester which is where I'm from Andre
Alki fought on the card and we went to
the weigh-ins at Manchester I remember
it like clear as day I must have been
like 12 13 years old at the time Alki
got on the scales mate with these like
cream joggers on he had the fangs you
know
he had like a long hair and he put his
arm up and he was ripped and the crowd
just went like he big dudy and the crowd
just went wild so when I fought owski
even though like now he's he's
definitely on the back end of his career
he was on the back end of his career
when I fought him still but he was on a
sixf fight win streak when I fought him
so he was like he was coming back a
little bit but mate in that fight he
punched me in the
eyeball and it wasn't a poke or anything
but I couldn't see him for most of the
fight so I hurt him early on when he had
him on the fence I just unloaded because
I couldn't really see I couldn't really
see where I was punching so that wasn't
my best performance but definitely to
get people like that on your resume is
like I don't know I believe in like the
rub that's what we call it now he like
the rub and like when you fought good
guys like that you get a bit of a don't
know if it's com like it's obviously
like a mental thing but I felt like I
belong after I fought him yeah
confidence for you has been a really
interesting thing to watch that grow
because like I've seen a lot more of it
recently um but uh the volov one must
have been one that you got a lot of
confidence from because the way you
implemented takedowns with standup was
one of the best we've ever seen from a
heavyweight it was like there was one
point where he commits you roll under
take him down that was beautiful thank
you
um I I think my confidence has gone up a
few notches since then I think that was
definitely a good performance but since
I injured my knee that was like it
sounds [__] weird every every time I
see it I can see people looking at me
like what are you talking about but
honestly that was a best thing probably
that ever happened to me is me injuring
money did it enable you to see the
bigger picture massively massively mate
so like I got signed to the UFC in the
pandemic sorry before the pandemic but
then the pandemic hit so it was like I
was just taking mate any fight that Ur
anywhere and obviously when you first
start with the promotion you don't get
any say in anything basically you don't
say where you fight who you fight even
now I don't really say who I fight but I
was just may just jumping on any fight
that I could against anyone and uh I
didn't really get a time to like think
do you know what I mean I didn't I was
just stuck at home stuck in the gym
going for fights winning coming back and
then onto the next one
basically and uh I knew there was some
stuff that wasn't right in my life which
I won't go into too much um is there
anything you can't show just I I was
just bit easily distracted you know like
I I was just trying to I always had in
my mind that like I I definitely
suffered with my confidence because this
this is why I've had so long to think
about it like I had a year off so I got
a lot of times to think about it is I
always wanted like a built-in excuse of
not taking my diet seriously not taking
my recovery seriously not getting the
best training that I could get um all
kinds of different like not doing I
didn't do any strength and condition at
all all this like different stuff it was
always like ah well if I lost I can just
blame it on X Y and Zed do you know what
I mean and that's not the way that a
champion holds himself you know what I
mean if and then I thought you know when
I was injured I thought like right I've
got two choices here I can either [__]
this thing off and go and just be a
normal regular person living a normal
regular job or I've got to go light all
in and I've got to leave behind me going
to the pub me going to someone's
granddad's 70th because they asked me I
want to be polite like I just I think I
just got better at like saying no and
putting myself first and that's uh
something that I really struggle with
like I've always been like a a quiet
yeah a people pleaser like a quiet kid
growing up and I think I just wanted
everyone to like like you like me yeah
exactly and I'd be scared to be like
actually no I'm not doing that because
I've got to [__] put myself first
here and when I got the injury mate I
decided listen I'm going to go both feet
in I'm going to go balls to the wall
with this thing and if it doesn't work
out at least I can look back mate in 20
years and go this [__] didn't work
out but I tried my best so I'm proud of
myself and uh since then mate it's been
working out pretty good so I'm really
happy and it is a difficult thing to do
for someone like me like I said I was a
shy kid I spent a lot of my the time in
the gym I didn't have too many friends
or anything like that I mean I got
friends obviously but I wasn't like the
popular kid at school or anything and I
just wanted to be liked by everybody to
be honest and and that's the way it it
was and I started getting a big success
and I felt like everyone started liking
me more and I was like oh I need to go
this place with this person need to do
this with this person this person is
telling me I should do this I'll listen
to him but when I got injured I was like
no actually [__] that I know exactly
what I need and I need to execute that
and since I did it it's been so powerful
mate I feel amazing you don't I don't
know you know how lucky you are in a way
because as someone who didn't sort of
get that message earlier in my own
success like I was like being generous
to me is a great quality to have uh but
you can be generous to a fault right
what I I was an idiot about it I
literally just was helping people who
didn't deserve it just like allowing
anyone who wanted to be on the gravy
train come on I'll help you out me too
and uh and it you think you're doing the
right thing but like there is a line and
to to to realize that and go actually no
I'm [__] myself here in the long run
and then you've got this thing about
sabotaging yourself so that you've got
an excuse J Jones used to do that
ironically before every fight have a
blowout it's a confidence issue mate
it's a and that's uh it's something
before my injury before I had year off I
never had time to think about this kind
of stuff and it was always like oh it's
going well so far so I don't want to
change anything do you know what I mean
it was a bits of superstitious like that
I was like right this is going really
good it's a bad time to change something
now I can't be changing this this and
this because but M there was so many
stuff wrong um like in inside the gym
outside the gym and and stuff like that
like I needed to just do you know what
changed me is when you lay on the floor
mate holding your leg in front of 22,000
her own fans Who start leaving because
you it's that's a [__] ego death and
uh wow like that that changed me for the
better like it was absolutely awful at
the time like it one of the worst things
that happened in my life it was terrible
but ultimately I came back so much
stronger and now like my career is so
good but not only that is my life so so
good as well like saying no to people
and sometimes people you know do you
want to come down this there no I'm not
doing it do you want to come for this
session there'll be this no I'm just you
just do your thing and I'll just do my
thing and uh I watched some some thing
online I'm not trying to be like it's no
motivational speak or nothing like that
but it was like a some something and
it's just like let them and it was
anything I just let just let them just
let them do that let them say this let
them say that it doesn't matter like I'm
doing my thing and
I'm going to be the [__] best in the
world and if I'm not the best in the
world at least I [__] tried my best
to be the best in the world so that was
uh the injury and the whole recovery
process was super powerful for me time's
the greatest story telling mate and I'm
sure that those decisions will prove
that and one of the things that cuz I I
watch almost all your interviews proper
Fanboy and I've been watching like the
the Bisping stuff and there was a moment
on that channel where you were in a chat
with Bisping you were talking like I am
going to apply myself 100% And I'm not
going to leave no stone unturned and I
am going to be champion and you'd never
it all been like very slow and I want to
take my time and then all of a sudden it
was a 180 switch flick and then you also
mentioned that you changed your training
so that now it was all heavyweights uh
inspired by the fury gym uh and you
definitely got you know Advantage from
that right 100% um and also I I go to
Holland as well as train with a guy
called Rico verhoven are you familiar
with him he's like the literally
statistically the best kickboxer in the
world like he's been the glory
heavyweight champion for 10 years
unbelievable and him and their team and
Peter Fury and their team and like I
trained with Peter Fury for a long time
it's all based around the fighter and
that's what I kind of wanted is I I
wanted that and uh yeah as a big guy
mate you need big guys simple as that
like there's no hiding from that that's
why I was in a position to take the
pavlovic fight because yeah I didn't
have a fight booked and I wasn't fit
like I would be for a fight but I I I
knew where I was at
whereas before I wasn't training with
heavyweights regular and I just yeah
mate s like my what's the difference
when you compare the two in what sense
like as in you know beforehand you were
training with middle weights like
heavyweights then just heavy weights how
does that change you oh mate heavyweight
mma's almost got his own rules in my
opinion like it's so much more
exhausting training with big guys as
opposed to um like small like mate if
you trying to [__] grapple with a guy
who's 110 kilo 120 k excuse me it's
massively different than grappling with
a guy 80 kilo it's
just you you have to be a heavyweight to
realize I think I think um the smaller
guys think ah it's not a big issue but
it may it is it it is simple as that
like I'm a heavyweight I know exactly
what it feels like to have a [__] guy
my size or bigger on top of you and a
and a middleweight or a welterweight or
a lightweight on top of you it's
massively different then you get the
call for pav pavlovic who is a scary
[__] like and and and you know
you must have been like when you got the
call was there a moment where you're
like [__] me or were you just completely
yes um I was just completely yes you
know I I just think that there's not
many chances like this come around and I
think well I knew 100% fact the matter
is like if I'm watching on TV at home in
the UK I'm definitely not going to win
that I can guarantee that I can put all
the money I've got on that so I just
thought why not you know I was in the
shape that I'm normally in um as you
said pavic is a [__] scary guy man
and and MMA fans are so fickle like I
see people now being like pav rich is
not that good hey come on now the amount
of messages that I got of people being
like rip Tom Tom's going to get he's
going to get steamrolled in 30 seconds
cuz mate Steve peric didn't want to
fight pavich s Gan didn't want to fight
like all these guys are turning him down
yeah and I took it on two less than two
weeks notice so um I think that just
again that's a testament to my training
though I think like I knew exactly where
I was at because I'm training with the
big boys day in day out so I know that
oh I had a spy last week with so and so
he's he's pretty good and I managed to
do the rounds with him and I managed to
get him off in this position oh my
cardio was all right in there my
conditioning is good I'm pretty strong I
turned him in this spot so that's why
it's so important I think to train with
heavy weights cuz you know where you're
at at all times and like having that
knowledge the the power and Devastation
that a guy like that can cause uh you
you said afterwards I was probably more
scared for this one how do you walk into
the cage how are you dealing with the
nerves for someone like that oh it's
scary I would like it myself it's so
scary it's so SC I'm not even going to
like beat around the bush it's so scary
um as soon as like the as soon as it
gets going though I'm all right to be
honest I'm more nervous like the weak
the weak of the fight like you get to
the especially cuz like I was in New
York time change uh um all that stuff it
Mak it's just scary is it when you're
about to go to sleep is it is there a
time of day when it sort of Crips in
your head of [__] me the sky could
really killed me yeah just all the time
it's just it's just really scary mate
I'm not going to um say it's not it is
like I'm scared each and every time I
fight and I used to think when I was
like an amateur and even before I did
MMA when I used to like box and and I'd
be having kickboxing fights I'd be in
jiujitsu come like I've done the full
spectrum of martial arts and competing
them all I used to be really nervous for
all them as well and I used to think
watch the UFC and think look at them
guys they're not even nervous look at
them it must be so easy when you get to
that level mate doesn't get any easier
doesn't get any easier at all but what I
do is uh something that I've learned a
lot from the internet from watching GSP
gsp's actually told me personally we'
had a few lengthy chats about it as well
he's
like you have to accept fear because
it's not going away like fear makes you
super sharp and once I accepted fear
that it's going to be there and that I
can't because I always I always say I
used to have two fights I used to be
fighting my opponent I used to fight be
fighting myself and I used to be like
listen just trying to push my I used to
be fighting the fear more so than my
opponent he'd be like I need to stop
thinking like this this is not I'm
supposed to think now I just accept this
is how you're supposed to feel and this
is actually going to help me be sharper
in my fight and that's something that I
accepted a few fights ago and uh
probably maybe around the time I just
got in the UFC actually so seven or
eight fights ago and once they accepted
that it's just give me a whole new
confidence I think they might have been
Brandon sha who said that the the worst
he ever thought was when he wasn't
scared and I've heard a few Fighters say
that like that's when you actually
should be [__] worried cuz your reflexes
everything ain't going to be on point
and when you were in there you're
obviously moving around him you're on
your bike and pavlovic catching oh he W
me yeah he did whack me what did that
feel like like when I'm in there and I'm
just emotionless I'm not thinking about
anything apart from what I'm doing and
uh by the way that that's an absolutely
fantastic spot to be in in life in
general where you don't have anything
else to think about apart from what
you're doing right now it's really rare
I've got a really active mind so it's
really rare that I can be in that that's
why I love this sport so much is because
I'm I'm constantly questioned like I'm I
love it I absolutely love that aspect is
I can find out who I am every time I
fight and that's pretty rare mate that's
pretty rare like people run away from
that and I try and embrace it as much as
I can because the sport is uh it really
[__] puts into perspective this is
like focusing in the moment if you're
not focused in the moment mate you're G
to get knocked out and it's great spot
for that so I absolutely love it for
that but when he whacked me I actually
thought it's not as bad as I thought to
be honest he he clipped me with he he
missed the right hand I slipped it a
little bit he got me with the left H he
started knock he knocked my gun Shield
out a little
bit and uh I started retreating back and
like readjusting my gum shield and I
think that he thought he I think that he
thought
he hurt me yeah but he didn't I was just
readjusting my G Shield so he came
forward with a couple more and I slipped
him I got out the way and I think he was
a bit demoralized after that to be
honest cuz usually he whacks someone and
that's the beginning of the end so um
it's a bad habit to get into I guess
what getting whacked well no for him to
to be expecting you to be H because then
if the one like all of a sudden and
we've seen this before the one guy who
can take that shot you you [__] yourself
like deont Wilder had it with Tyson Fury
but you know right he's so heavy-handed
though like seven first round knockout
Knockouts in the UFC against top 15 guys
is [__] unbelievable the guy is an
absolute truck and I guarantee moving
forward he's going to knock a lot more
people out the guys in absolutely you
probably meet him again I'm sure I will
like I've only just turned 30 I think
he's like 31 32 we got at least another
five years left so young heavyweights
very young heavyweights yeah so so you
catch him you put him down y smash him
emotions pouring out can you sort of
describe what that felt like for me mate
um I was just really overwhelmed I
thought I was going to to be honest I I
definitely thought I had a good chance
of winning the fight I thought the it'
be later on but I have serious power as
well like I know that I do and something
else that I have over the other
heavyweights is they don't see the
punches I'm I'm not going to give away
what I do too much but they don't see
them I don't just stand in front of you
and unload the punches I do a lot of
subtle stuff that's hard to see from the
outside I was really overwhelmed and I
think obviously winning the title is
great and like that's my lifelong dream
but also the circumstances that I was in
there was a lot happened behind the
scenes so to speak I fight taking the
fight on two weeks notice I not being in
the best shape ever back inry also I
[__] injured my back yeah also I
didn't realize I was going to New York
until two days before cuz I couldn't get
a visa and I had to be in London like
[__] around a couple of times trying
to get a visa and when you got all that
resting on your shoulders mate it's it's
a lot it's like I'm very regimented with
my training I'm very regimented with my
life my routine is everything to me like
I do the same things every day and I
didn't have any of that in this training
camp not well I call it a training camp
it wasn't a training camp you can't
train for a fight in a week simple as
that so it was none of that I was way
out my comfort zone so I think it was
just pure relief more than anything it
was so great that bis you did a Bisping
and that Bisping went there and uh he
said he went into the locker room
beforehand and then you've seen him
afterward for English MMA fans for for
you know you like me we watched Bisping
take the belt off of rock hold to see
you guys have that moment was like [__]
me I could cry just watching this you
know what I mean what was that like just
KN that the The Godfather bisin he's
just he's he's my guy do you know what I
mean like we're good friends um I was
watching bisin mate sat off in the nose
beds in the menn arena at the time I
came I came down to uh I watched him in
Birmingham against Chris leben that
[__] years ago like I was just the
ultimate B fan and then when I'm
sometimes you know it's like you meet
people and you're like nah he's he's not
what I thought he would be uh but bis
Bin's like is that guy no Bin's that guy
and more like he's so he's such a nice
person and we have such a good
relationship personally as well um
Michael BisMan UFC champion aside it was
just nice to have Michael BisMan my
friend there suppored me it was great
there was a bit of criticism about the
performance you did obviously you got
caught and there's this thing that
people keep Li laying at you saying your
chins in the air
um I wondered what your response is to
people who say that uh I agree my chin
is in the out something I'm working on
um I have bad habits same as anybody
else I'm training every day to make them
better yeah um I wasn't expecting that
response fair play mate I'm I I think
that you can learn from anybody and I
can I can see my bad habits just as much
as anybody else I'm not going to sit
here and be like I am the ultimate
complete finished product right now like
I feel like I'm going to even when I'm
retired from fighting I'm still going to
going to be trying to improve my martial
art skills forever I'm a lifelong
martial artist um this thing never ends
I'm never going to be the complete
fighter I'm never going to be the
complete martial artist um to those
people who say yeah my Chin's in the air
yeah I shouldn't have took this shot
that shot I do this wrong that wrong um
mate I can see it more than anybody else
I'm a own biggest critic you don't have
to tell me the bad habits I'm making I
love the sport of MMA I love martial
arts I study martial arts I study myself
more than I study anybody else and um I
know what I need to work on and I'm
working on it every day has people been
changing how they treat you since then
because it's one thing to be tomasel UFC
fighter it's another thing to have the
belt visually it it hits people you know
like you're the king now yeah people
asking favors people talking you a
certain way what are you saying do you
know what I just try and keep my life
exactly the same you know I'm really
like it's t me a long time to get to the
point where I'm at so I want to keep it
that way I'm not into like these bougie
parties and celebrity living and puffing
bottles and wearing all nice jewelry and
and going on this and that and this
yacht and doing all that [__] obviously
I've got offers for that but it's just
not really my thing mate I I want to
stay I want to stay who I am cuz I'm
happy with myself and it's took me a
long time to get happy with myself and
I'm there so I just want to keep it like
that that's amazing to me because so
many fighters get to where they are by
insecurity like I look at Conor McGregor
for example uh and I think the fact that
he has this like small man syndrome
thing going on like he he wants to be
the biggest shining star in the room and
that's actually sparked a lot of his
success same with Floyd Mayweather
that's why they jewelry money that is
there BR whereas I think you being a big
guy probably helps you you don't have
this thing of I've got a chip on my
shoulder because I need to act like the
biggest hardest man in the room I am the
biggest hardest man in the room I don't
really have to prove that um you know
what I mean like yeah no I know exactly
what you mean I just don't um it's just
not really my personality mate to be
honest with you and I'm not going to
fake that like uh as I said I'm
very happy with the person I am now I'm
very um I try I try and have like good
morals I believe in like karma really
strongly and stuff like that so I try
and be honest and upfront with people
and and just just live it like that I'm
not really into like the flashy
lifestyle it doesn't really suit me like
it obviously um I like nice things just
as much as an X ey but I'm not going to
go flashing them in everyone's face like
I'm from a small working town so um if
someone did that in my town I'd be like
what a NOP look at this fell I don't
want I don't want everyone to look at me
like that well I see I when I got the
like money like cuz I'm a kid from
working class background big
I had this moment where I went out and
bought a loot of cars and stuff and I
driv them around I was like yeah I'm the
man and then like a few months I by I
was like God I look like such a [__]
prick I'm the same mate I've got a Range
Rover right and and it's it's not a it's
not some big fancy one it's beautiful I
love it um and people like oh why didn't
you get like a Lamborghini Urus and all
that it's like I can't be driving around
my town in that like a knob like a Range
Rover is big if suits me it's great and
uh I'm just happy with that yeah I don't
like you say there's there's some stuff
that people do and
I just don't want to be one of them well
bisbing me mentioned on my podcast he
was like he rang you up going tell the
wife get the handbags out get get the
house pick it's all happening and you
were like but I don't want to do that
yeah so um so like you're not
daydreaming about possessions it is
about the martial arts it's about
competition it's about Legacy um but
ironically I was talking about McGregor
before you have had a little bit of a
back and forth haven't we all um he he
sent you a tweet after you said he
weren't really fuss on his comeback
fight which I don't think was a bad
thing to say by any means um I basically
said that he would starve you of your
Jim King deal and kill you you [__]
disrespectful yada yada yada um what was
it like to have and I let me be clear a
man who you could absolutely annihilate
within a minute if do what you want with
him giving you death threats a little
bit weird because I don't I don't really
know Connor at all I've never even met
the guy um never had any beef with him
or anything and the the whole situation
came on a little bit weird so my friend
started a YouTube channel right cuz he's
my friend he came down the gym and
interviewed me and I did it because he's
my friend he doesn't have loads of
numbers on his uh doesn't have loads of
followers or loads of subscribers or
anything like that so it's a pretty
small in with a couple of hundred views
that's it it's not like a big Channel
and he asked me about McGregor are you
looking forward to McGregor's next fight
blah blah blah and I said oh to be
honest I'm not really uh I'm not really
that interested in Conor McGregor not
because I'm M I only really watch the
heavyweights and and bigger guys I'm not
as interested in the SM I just meant it
like that next whene he's [__]
sending me death threat Lo a tweet I'm
like mate how first of all how did you
even see that it's got like 300 views on
it and uh how are you offended I just
didn't I just found out must I just
didn't I was just a bit baffled by it
like what the [__] like this is uh like
I say this is my friend's YouTube
channel it's not like I'm not on MMA
hour or ESPN or anything calling out
yeah I'm not mate I'm not doing anything
like that he literally asked me and I
just said mate you know what I'm not
really that that interested in what
McGregor's doing and he just got really
offended by it and started getting all
violent and [__] but it didn't mean it
like that we've had Dana White uh come
out in the last couple of days on TNT
yes we're going to talk about that he
said um Tom Aspen will not get the fight
with either St b or Jones they will
fight each other next y as as someone
who is the the young hungry lion Jon
Jones and steep are on the Alder side of
their career to me the UFC was built on
the best fight and the best for weight
title of the world and it's clear that
you are the best how does that make you
feel well so let me start by saying I
absolutely love my sport I absolutely
love the sport of MMA UFC in particular
like I'm so proud to be fighting for the
best MMA organization in the world and
what that represents for me is the best
fighting the best and I'm a massive
boxing fan right I absolutely love the
the sport of boxing I [__] can't
stand the boxing model like there should
not be five six different world
champions at one weight and that's at a
minimum some some ways talking like 8
nine Champions at one weight let's find
out who the [__] guy is that's what I
that's what I want to find out like this
is there's two Champions now in the UFC
heavyweight division that's not right
mate it's not right simple as that you
can sugar coat all you want these Legacy
fights and whatever like my next fight
has to be for the Undisputed title why
would it like why would it do otherwise
like it's let's [__] find out who the
guy is simple as that all this Legacy
fight [__] I don't understand how that
can happen yeah let him have a legacy
fight but why for the Undisputed title
why you making the the rest of us wait
and I understand it's Jon Jones mate
he's a legend there's no person walking
this Earth who's a bigger Jon Jones fan
than me but this isn't boxing this isn't
guys avoiding each other this isn't the
number one guy fighting the number 10
guy let's find out who the [__] guy
is cuz I believe it's me so let let's
see this would be the first time in
history to my knowledge that an
Undisputed Champion would uh basically
not be fighting the interim Champion
that you always collaborate those two
belts and bring them together and and
unify and instead you have the option is
you defend it because Dan I white has
said it's what they deserve and I I find
that amazing because Dan I white for the
longest time has criticized boxing and
yet we have now finally got to a point
where Alexander yusk and Tyson Fury are
unifying but mate two two three years
too late yeah we don't like that's the
way boxing works is like M look at
people like Pacquiao and Mayweather
[__] five years on who's asked
anymore that's that's how I feel about
step and Jones exactly I don't care
about I because we've got the champion
right here it's very odd and obviously I
don't want to sit here slagging off my
bosses
but it's it's not right it's not right
like they can't be [__] two
heavyweight champions they can't be this
isn't boxing there's one guy there's one
face one name and let's find out who
that is I'm I'm surprised that Dan know
especially because of the the slating of
boxing and like now we like kind of now
doing worse than boxing because boxing
is actually getting attacked together a
little bit in in that regard and you're
saying the quote from Dano is it's what
they deserve the UFC has never been
about looking after people like Chuck
liell never got looked after like you
know it was Killers you want to be in
the UFC you're fighting Killers there's
no exceptions even for Dana White's best
friend there was no exceptions so to now
sit there and protect steep for Steep to
would deny a fight with pavlovic for
Steep to deny a fight with you and to
still get the title shot I understand
steep is you know he he's done well for
the UFC but like you don't get brownie
points this a't here for like we're here
to find out who the best is not to see
they see we uh it's it's frustrating for
the fans I and I personally think like
well I'll bring I'll get on to Jon
Jones's last uh quote about this because
he said um I faed the absolute toughest
competition the world has to offer for
15 years during camp for title defense
I've got a major injury yada yada yada
now I've got newcomers requesting my
Championship gets uh stripped I'm
assuming he's referring to you as the
newcomer zero wins over Legends I mean
it's hard to get a win over a legend
when none of them will touch you um zero
title defenses and already thinking you
call the shots to day Anda hilarious my
50 in career I've seen so many guys
supposed to be the next big thing
there's only been one Jon Jones never
forget that notice at no point does he
say when I come back I'll fight Tom
Aspen yeah yeah see so like as great as
you are I'm not seeing any confidence to
take you on what does that make you
think I'd be surprised if we got to
fight to be I I would love it and I
think he's aware of that you're just too
good for him at this point I I think
he's smart I think he's smart and if the
shoe was on the other foot I wouldn't
fight me either and that's not me
bigging myself up it's just like why
would you not fight a guy that's 42 43 a
million miles on the clock and then back
door it as opposed to fighting like this
guy who's just steamrolling everybody
yeah yeah and I think it's smart I don't
think he's scared Jon Jones mate he's
not scared of anybody but I think he's
just really smart and um but scared
though scared is a word though isn't it
it's about I fear what this man will do
to me and I don't think whether or not
it's fear but he understands that the
risk that you bring is significantly
greater than miic miic hasn't looked
miic has his best never looked like you
look like now let alone it's very uh
it's very strange so if we talking uh
like statistics or whatever like Jon
Jones has had one fight heavyweight
against Sanu let's be honest didn't
[__] want to be there onedimensional
as well s y and that was his one fight
in three years so he's had one fight at
heavyweight Stipe has had one fight in
four years and he got knocked out it's
[__] weird mate I don't um this is
this is actually worse than anything
boxing has ever done in terms of
protecting Fighters like because at
least in the heavyweight division at
some point you will fight a live dog
within three years yeah like and by the
time these guys do fight it'll be one
fight in four years one fight in 5 years
like how can that possibly represent the
best fighting the best the the sport
moves so quickly I couldn't agree more M
it blows my mind um and and even look in
the S gone fight with Jon Jones before
the takedown Jon Jones looked slow he he
that body shot he through where he
missed him completely I'm like you know
if you do that at Tom asol your head's
coming clean off mate like I agree um I
do agree but it's frustrating so
frustrating it's uh you've covered
basically every point there is to cover
and I just don't understand it mate and
it's difficult for me to speak in
interviews and stuff about it because
everyone's like you [__]
disrespecting one of the best no I'm not
at all
I want I want a shot like I want my shot
simple as that I think I'm the [__]
number one heavyweight in the world
right now I truly truly believe it let
me prove it that's all I'm asking I'm
not let's not forget though to Jon
Jones's last few fights at like
heavyweight yeah he did not look good
man know he looked poor like going to a
decision against Anthony Smith with all
due respect credible competitor it
didn't look good and you and also my
caveat on every Jon Jones fight up until
heavyweight was you were a heavyweight
who drained yourself down to light
heavyweight and if you look at his
actual resume most of the guys he fought
were middleweight M went to middleweight
Shogun went to middleweight yeah cha
sunnon middleweight and like CH sunnon
wanted you on 24 hours notice and you
wouldn't show up for that yeah so I just
think that like I think Jon Jones as
great as his legacy is it's incomplete
without fighting a live dog at
heavyweight and you are that I'd hold my
hands up if he fights you then you're
legitimately the heavyweight champion of
the world because it's the best fight
and the best but a win Ser gone who was
never the champion does not make you you
know it's it I
genuinely all hype and talk aside I
genuinely want to find out who's the
best me or him because I think he's one
of the best fighters ever I I literally
believe that 100% I'm a massive massive
Jon Jones fan I want to find out is what
I'm doing in the gym and what I'm doing
in my is that right to [__] beat the
best guy ever it will be and I think it
is I believe it is and I want to test it
but obviously right now it doesn't seem
like I'm getting the opportunity for it
well when you look at the way he fought
against OSP big guy yeah uh is Alexander
yeah big guy same with Dominic Reyes
yeah Dominic Reyes all of these 6'4 guys
who he hasn't got a major size advantage
over and strength advantage over he
struggled big time they did not have the
speed and power you do and with the look
he defends well but with your ability to
connect and hurt people I just don't see
away from to win that fight I completely
shocked I completely and and I don't
know what to do to get that fight do you
know what I mean I don't know what else
I can do I [__] took the fight
shortest not is possible like any any
less than that's undoable you can't take
it you can't fly across the world mate I
didn't have a Visa so I couldn't have
got there any sooner than that um I
don't know what else I can do apart from
go over knock out the scariest guy by
the way pavic was he was the backup
fight he was training for three months
for that fight I didn't even get a
[__] week so I went over there
knocked him out nobody thought he could
lose he was steamrolling everyone if
that doesn't get me the fight what else
can I do I don't know what the [__] is
going on I'm just I'm just s and then
they're talking about like defending an
interim and stuff and it's like well
first of all who else is defending an
interim I don't know of any I I don't
know either I don't know and if I've got
to defend an interim against a genuine
Contender then I should be the one with
the [__] Undisputed belt like if you
st thought it should be undis yeah yeah
yeah no he's fighting Stipe who's 42 or
43 whatever he is million miles on the
clock if I had to fight someone like ala
seral Gan volov again all all them kind
of people who are actually like in the
prime and good like that's a bit of a
[__] end of the stick for me do you know
I think he he's fighting for the
Undisputed and I'm defending an in
another thing I really can't understand
is the fact that the UFC and all all all
boxing fighting even wrestling do this
right you get the guys with the miles on
the clock they're at the end they're
almost ready and what you do is you have
a changing of the god right you go now
we're going to line you up against the
hungry lion we're going to hope that you
lose to the hungry lion push him to the
Moon we've got a UK guy who's very uh
likable and every man who has the UK
audience behind him I can't think of a
better way to um you know attach the
star power to you and build you up more
than by having you fight either St I
also don't know I don't have an answer
for it I don't know what else I feel
like it's Jones's Legacy is is intwined
with the UFC's Legacy and what they're
thinking is like he's the Michael Jordan
for us and if he does lose it affects
the UFC's overall brand because then you
know Silva lost GSP lost like we don't
really have a guy to hang with hat on
and go he was the goat I don't know I
you might be I have not a [__] clue
mate I don't know I'm just over here
like how many fights a year do you get
offered uh you're supposed to get three
or in my previous contracts it was three
I've got a new contract now uh as a
champion I'm sure not his fights he
better pay you know what I mean right
um I think probably two now or something
like that I don't know but um the reason
I'm asking is when I look through CU
I've got a bit of a conspiracy theory
about the UFC heavyweight title in that
for whatever reason I hadn't really
connected the dots I was like okay D
Daniel Cormier s miic now John Jones it
is staggering how rarely that belt gets
defended is it oh yeah comp to Israel
ARA at middleweight who seems to defend
it weakly uh the welterweight belt want
to average that probably like once a
year yeah which which for for for a
promotion that kind of you know with
certain Fighters you've been grafting
your balls off some of these Lads in
terms of defending their belt twice
three times a year minimum Israel adna
three times a year Kamar Usman was two
or three times a year so to have it so
different a heavyweight across three
different champions for example I was
like is there a a monetary but they they
seem to operate so much slower at
heavyweight and for you to be twice a
year is surprising to me cuz I'm
thinking let's throw you as many fights
as we can I actually don't know I don't
have a decent answer for you
unfortunately but uh I have been very
active for heavyweight I've had
uh eight nine fights in three years
which is quite a lot and an injury yeah
and an injury and I think that um yeah
the injury kept me off for a year so
probably been averaging a little bit
more but um I think definitely with big
guys see the training takes out of us a
lot more just going back to what we
spoke about with the heavy weights and
stuff like heavy weights are banged up a
lot more than smaller guys it just takes
more out of your body like um if you
look at big guys that generally go into
like rubby or basketball or if they're
American they're going to like American
football and stuff like that it's not
often they're training for like 25
minutes scraps with someone in an arena
do you know what I mean so it's more of
a small guy sport in general I think
there's less guys to fight at
heavyweight and I think that
heavyweights just aren't
as readily available as much as some of
the smaller guys do you think you're
just going to sit there and wait for
them to offer another solution or are
you cuz for you your progress right now
to sit out for what could be another
nine months then they fight if they both
make it through one injad which the rate
they're going seems unlikely you then
have another six month like it's just
not viable is it to sit out it's not
ideal definitely not but um right now I
guess we've just got to wait there's no
I don't don't really have a choice right
now I don't know what else I can do um
my next fight has to be for the
Undisputed has to be there's no I'm the
interim Champion right now the interim
means if you actually translate the word
interim it means like in waiting so it
means
like the the champ the champ while the
Champ's unavailable MH so when he's
available exactly exact it's not [__]
it's not rocket science mate is it it's
not rocket science I don't I'm just Asad
as everybody else with it so if they
come to you and go we're going to offer
you uh sir gone yeah to defend the
interim title are you thinking you might
say No it should be for Undisputed I
don't know I'm I'm in a difficult spot
to say that right now but I think my
next fight should be Undisputed I've
never ever you can ask any of the UFC
staff any of my team anyone I've never
ever turned down a fight in my life and
I'll continue to not turn down a fight
but I deserve deserve to fight for the
Undisputed title next 100% % in terms of
your heavy bait go yeah who is that oh
he a tough one I loved Kan Velasquez in
his prime loved him but if you're
talking about the heavyweight goat I
think statistically you got to go uh
Stipe statistically but I think K
Velasquez was better than him if that if
that makes any performances he was
Unreal mate like if you compare the
greatest performance of Stevie put on to
Kane Kane was the complete fighter me
like I the way he moved he was so good
at everything he was just for me he was
better than Fedor yeah definitely I I
completely agree um see I don't like
talking like oh if if uh Kane in his
prime thought stpe in his prime because
that's just [__] talk it's like the
I hate the goat conversation not the
goat sorry I hate the pound-for-pound
conversation I think it's absolute
bollocks we might as well talk about
[__] Superman against Iron Man do you
know what I mean it's it's impossible
it's all make believe but uh for me Kane
in his prime was [__] he was like no
one else he was incredible he had this
sort of Steely demeanor and then like
for me the the the way he perfectly
threw the leg kicks and uh all of his
technique was so there was no fat on it
the the Iron Man that he was in terms of
his cardio I mean you could argue he
didn't have the power of someone like
you but he had everything else PR he
unre he was absolutely unbelievable I
absolutely love never actually met Kane
I'd love to meet him and he just seems
like such a nice guy as well like seems
dead chilled and what think of what he's
gone through lately for those who don't
know I'll just explain he he got into a
situation where um he found out I
believe his daughter was being abused by
a teacher of some sort obviously as a
man would especially a man like Kan went
after the guy chasing him down the
motorway shooting at his car uh and I
think they've arrested him for attempted
murder so yeah um I
think as a father
myself and I think a lot of other father
out there and a lot of other men even
without children would say that's what
I'd do if that happened to me blah blah
blah Kane [__] did it and I think
[__] fair play to him and I think he
he shot the wrong guy or something
didn't he is that right the guy who was
driving away had his died in the car
right okay um it's a shame that he got
shot because he was obviously innocent
so that's not
ideal but it's [__] absolutely
disgusting what went on and I think that
free Kane is what I say I know he's for
free man now I don't know if he I heard
he's got another trial coming up
something I I hope he gets minimal for
what he's done you'd think so I mean
I've only ever heard of one other the
case like this I don't know if you've
ever seen the footage of this Kea uh it
was a karate teacher molested some boy
and the father of the Boy Might Have
Been a former cup or whatever and
they're bringing him through the airport
and there's a guy on a telephone and he
just pulls the gun out and shoots this
karate It's the dad right he literally
been hiding there for however long
waiting for this guy and they got it
gave him minimal time because they were
like grounds of insan
so you'd think that there'd be an
acceptance to that I do wonder I worry
about the fact that the way Kane looks
like brown pride that's the issue in it
is like see I say all the time I feel
way safer in a bar full of UFC fighters
than I do a bar full of Regular People
regular yeah regular people honestly I
hand on Heart Like that's how I feel
like there's some of the everyone's ego
not everyone 95% of people's ego are in
check when you're when you're in MMA
fight because you get beat up on a
regular basis and uh yeah it goes
against you though for someone who
doesn't know that he's like some lawyer
who doesn't know really what MMA is they
think cage fighter see the skin head the
cauliflower ears and like you say the
brown pride tattoo and all that it
doesn't look good in that regard they
see that he's a cage fight former UFC
champion it doesn't look good but um and
I know a few people who know Kane and
and they say he's a great guy so I can
only go off that what do you make of
Alex Pereira talking about becoming a
three Division champion what cuz that
would be a very interesting welcoming to
hit you know if you were going to do
yeah the title fight a way to make that
spiced up a bit would be a double champ
situation where he's trying to take that
belt from you would you entertain that
well listen to this right we're in New
York he we obviously fought on the same
C being him never met him before never
um know a few of his um teammates and
stuff I know a couple of his coaches and
uh Glo to sh and stuff like we've met
before so pretty friendly he was quite
Frosty when I met him um and I don't
know him personally I didn't know if he
was just like that if he was just yeah
he's not he's definitely not happy
chappie do you know what I
mean so um spent a bit of time together
obviously there's a language bar and
stuff he does really speak English that
I'm aware of at least um and we went to
did the press conference we sat next to
each other he was literally I was I was
here he was
there got off the press conference and
i' said oh like how was it
I said you know that Alex Pereira he
said yeah I said he thinks he can beat
me you know and M was like what do you
mean I don't know I can just tell I can
I literally could feel of him that did
he want you to feel it I don't know I
don't he wasn't he wasn't postering he
wasn't like trying to intimidate me or
nothing I just felt
like he had in his mind maybe I'm just
making it up I have no idea but I've
never done it with anyone before and I'm
not like that insecure guy being like
he's trying to fight me I'm not like
that at all I just felt like when when I
heard that he wants to move up to
heavyweight I wasn't surprised I felt
like he was like sizing me up a little
bit maybe that's just the way he is
maybe I read it completely wrong but uh
I remember coming off the press
conference I said to my dad I'm sure he
was like I feel like I I almost got the
feeling from him like I would get from
an opponent before I would fight him do
you know what I mean cuz he had it in
his mind I think so but saying that mate
two three days away from a fight maybe
that's just the way he acts in general I
don't know I might have been reading the
situation completely wrong called it but
when I see when I when I saw that
headline that he's moving up to heavy he
going to move up to heavy I was like ah
that does make a bit of sense but maybe
I was completely what do you make of
that fight between you and him I mean
what a what a striking match it could
make yeah I think he's great I think
he's amazing I'm massive fan of his I
actually um as I said I train I train
with Rico verhoven who's the glory
heavyweight champion he was the glory
light heavyweight champion on
middleweight so I was aware of who he
was before he even got to the UFC I was
a fan of him then um I think it makes an
amazing fight to be honest like if he if
if that's something that we can explore
later down the line um as I said to you
I've never turned a fight down in my
life so can't be in the Talk of the Town
right now one of the guys I wanted to
ask you about was Ian Gary oh yeah uh
what a character divisive uh divisive
very disliked actually by a lot of
people um what do you make of his skill
set and also just his personality the
fact that he's been kicked out of all
these J
he's making Buzz y yeah well I've I I
wouldn't like to say I'm friends with
angari because I'm not but I've known of
him and who he is for a long time we're
on cage Warriors together so um he's
always been like a Brash mouthy out
there character even on cage Warriors um
I think his skill sets really good I
think he's potentially a future Champion
even though that weight division is
[__]
stacked
um and he's getting he's getting the
brunt of it at the minute I know his
wife as well um I've known her for quite
a while as well as I said I don't I'm
not sitting here saying that we're
friends because we're not I just know
him from the scene uh the pair of them
has any of this surprised you knowing
them from back in the day
no no I know uh it's common
knowledge OK dog yeah I get you I mean
you seem like a guy who can kind of read
situations well and see things coming as
you say with this Pereira sort of uh man
I don't I might have read that [__] it I
might be way off I might be way off to
the heavy he call he says he is he says
he is maybe one day we'll meet but uh
was his coach was actually saying oh we
should train together after the fights
he was like oh maybe we can start some
training out like sure absolutely maybe
that's just the way he is Francis and
garu Y for uh Tyson Fury your old mate
um not my me but I I do I have seen that
interview I've seen hell of an interview
actually one of my favorites I've ever
done to be fair um but in terms of uh
inu's performance I think he shocked a
lot of people you shared the ring with
Tyson you've obviously fought at the
level in garu has and you know you would
have been fighting him if he wouldn't
for gone to the pfl what did you make of
the fight still two months on I'm
shocked by it can't believe it I cannot
believe that that happened and I've seen
a lot of people saying oh Tyson didn't
train for it Tyson's people and my
people are such are pretty close in we
have mutual friends and and you know my
one of my coaches knows one of his Co he
took that fight deadly serious man he
trained hard for it he trains hard for
all his
fights very very shocked mate I did not
know that Francis could do that and you
got to respect him you got to absolutely
respect what Francis zanu's done he's
stuck to his guns he stuck it out with
the UFC rolled it out left went and got
this massive pfl
contract now he's turned to boxing he's
making shitloads of money out of it and
he goes in there mate and [__] holds
his own if not beats like I'm not a
boxing judge I can't score boxing I
don't understand it properly I don't not
even though I'm he dropped him so he
dropped him even though I'm a massive
boxing fan I don't claim to be able to
score a 10 round fight cuz I don't know
it that well I can score a five round
MMA fight no problem but boxing I'm not
as sure he definitely held his own and
dropped him which to me was out of this
world I think he's done Absolut
absolutely unbelievable both in the
fight and his career and he should be
extremely proud of himself the thing
that I was thinking which you've alluded
to earlier about heavyweight MMA is
almost a sport on its own heavyweight
boxing is the same for me and that you
know this these light away guys who can
throw a million punches and take a
million it ain't the same one wrong move
in your [__] and I think as someone
who's met Francis yeah I was trying to
tell all my boxing mates like this guy
is an athlete is right up there with
Deontay Wilder and all of these
heavy-handed guys but if anything he can
take a punch and he isn't going to just
be manhandled you can't just lean on him
like the classic Fury things that he
does and I just wondered like you know
you're watching Francis you're faster
than Francis you can do things Francis
can't even you know and I I wondered
what you were thinking about your own
chances in a boxing ring if the time
ever comes uh i' I've actually had a
Prof professional boxing fight myself um
that was something I was actually
thinking of doing at one point is boxing
um it's something that I I definitely do
before my career is over but right now I
feel like I'm nowhere I'm nowhere near
satisfied mate with what I've done like
yeah I'm the heavyweight champion right
now but I've got so much more work to do
mate I've not like won the title and I'm
like yes I've achieved it what's next
I'm like yeah I've got where I wanted to
go but [__] me there's some Absolut
Beast behind me and they've Absolut like
the next five years mate of my life are
going to be [__] a grind they're
going to be tough they're going to be in
the gym working I'm going to be in
fights all over the world getting
dropped getting back up and being
exhausted constantly and going through
the [__] pain to get where I want to
do go to be satisfied and uh you don't
want the distraction of thinking not to
like I was asked in an
interview um what like about it and I
didn't answer that way I answered by
saying oh yeah like he say oh would you
ever try boxing I was like oh yeah I
guess yeah yeah I'd be interested in it
and then next minute his headlines out
Tomas spol I boxing career next and I'm
like no it's not like that it's
something that i' definitely explore
especially if like the the money and
stuff is unbelievable in boxing I think
that's great so it's something that
potentially do before I've retired but
right now I've got so many massive
challenges in front of me in the UFC
that I've just got to focus on that yeah
I think you're spot on with that
attitude because like you are just
almost uh I look at you like a weirdly a
young kid in the heavyweight division
even though you're top of it and I think
that what you can achieve is
unbelievable like what what the Legacy
you can make as bising said as well the
reason I just find this interesting is I
think the reason inaru is such a problem
for these heavyweights is the level of
athlete years and I look at you and I
see when I look at the other top guys
you to me are like the Anthony Joshua of
the UFC in terms of a freak athlete
and that means if you did jump in the
ring and you did fine-tune the skills
you'd be a [__] problem for them lot
I think I've done a l have done a lot of
boxing sparring how was it it's
different to MMA and I think that a lot
of MMA fighters who go yeah I'm just
going to go into boxing and it doesn't
work like that mate punching is
definitely a part of our sport punching
is a small percentage of what you need
to be good at like um it's probably
barely
10% of of what you need to be good at is
punching and uh punching for boxers is
what they've done every day since they
were 8 10 12 years old up until they're
in the 30s so there's a lot a lot of
differences there and I I stopped doing
M for like two three years cuz I thought
I was going to box and by the end of the
three years or two years whatever it was
I was sparring regular with high level
boxers I was doing all right but at
first mate I was getting twatted all the
time and uh that's something that takes
time what was Spar and Tyson Fury so the
first time ever sparred him was I was
young man I was probably like 22 it was
before he fought CLI yeah he I don't
think he had the fight then it was like
after he fought whoever the number one
Contender was or whatever before then it
was after that this was like Prime fury
like the move Peter Fury coached mate
unbelievable Peter Fury just to just to
drop in there he's [__] some coach
mate that his style is is great like if
I ever switch over to boxing he still
coaches me now like we still go down
there sessions touch all the time he's a
great family friend of like mine and my
dad's and stuff the whole Fury family
are actually but um yeah if I ever want
to switch over to boxing uh he he'll be
my coach definitely I agree with you in
terms of like a lot of MMA fighters are
probably getting carried away looking at
Inu like I feel like Inu and maybe
yourself and one or two others are the
anomalies like you have to be a freak
athlete to be able to have and like you
know Connor yeah he he actually looked
pretty good against Mayweather but still
wasn't good enough Tyron Woodle even and
against Jake Paul uh got flattened
eventually uh what do you make of
influencer
boxing see a lot of MMA fighters hate on
it and I I just I just think you know
what if you're Mak your money at it and
you enjoy it [__] go for it man the
like the world's yours do whatever you
want like if the these guys enjoy boxing
and obviously they are like they
influencers whatever the YouTubers
instagrammers whatever the [__] hell
they do I I'm not familiar with a lot of
them but um I just think if you like
boxing and you want to test yourself and
you can make money out of it go on box
like why is everyone so hung up on the
fact that oh these guys don't deserve
well listen if the shoe was on the other
foot and you could get millions of
pounds for going fighting someone and
you weren't very good at it will you do
it or not of course you do it so I don't
see a lot of it comes from jealousy
don't it like I think that your average
five and0 guy is probably getting paid a
couple of grand for a fight if and these
guys are getting you know millions and
the can't box and and the guys who are 5
and0 getting a couple of grand are
looking at and being like I want to be
where you are so I'm just going to hate
on you and uh I m I just think fair play
cuz it takes bollocks mate to step in
there under any circumstances one of
your old myths is actually getting into
influencer boxing I think who's this Dar
oh we love till we love till around here
I'm excited to see how he gets on uh I
think it might be in in the the company
I do commentary for Misfit so that's
influenc is he definitely doing that cuz
I'm unsure whether he's doing like
normal boxing or influencer boxing well
I don't think he's going to fight
YouTubers I think they're going to put
him in there with maybe a Perry or a
level like a tough GE who's a real
fighter I don't think they're going to
you know have him easy fights by any
means but how do you think he will do in
the boxing ring how do you see that
going Till's got great hands man and and
till has got a bit of
a I don't know if he's like a lot of
fans have kind of turned against him a
little bit but I guess that's the game
that you play when you're big and mouthy
and and stuff like that like that's his
kind of stick if you like is to do that
and sometimes you get on the wrong end
of it but uh he's had a bit of a bad run
in the UFC his body was an awful shape
like his knees were smashed and
everything yeah um and he's got great
Till's got some good hands man some good
hands and I'm sure that when he I've not
seen him train for a while I know he's
been at the boxing for a couple of years
now so I don't know but even before any
of that like he's been a lifelong tie
boxer he's been tie boxing since he was
like eight nine years old or something
he's now in his 30 so M the guy can
definitely throw a punch he can punch
hard and I think they'll do well
definitely I looked at his last fight in
the UFC against uh uh yeah and he got
you know oh two losers again they got
you a lot of [__] for it and now looking
back at it you're like you nearly
[__] had him you know gone Still's
good mate Still's good that that's aged
like a fine way in that fight yeah like
I think a lot of people were harsh on
him for that and now you know um drias
is fighting for the title yeah so like
how how far away from the top is T I
kind of wish he'd stuck at the UFC and
not gone boxing but I guess we'll find
out once he makes the cash if he wants
to I look forward to it mate I'll tune
in and uh if possible I'll be there live
watching it I I support till and uh yeah
I think he'll he'll do just fine mate
I'm sure he'll do just fine I want to
talk about your dad a bit because he
obviously You' mentioned him a couple of
times and we see in this moment where
you put the belt on him in the kids prop
a heartwarming moment but your dad like
yourself is kind of um he's not trying
to hug the Limelight he was very much
like okay thanks very much what what
what has it been like on this journey
between you and him son [__] good
luck getting my out on an interview or
in a picture because he don't like any
of that stuff he likes it I mean I don't
mind it I'm I'm he growing on me now I
guess I guess I got to embrace it a bit
but my I don't want to he don't want his
face on the camera he don't want to be
mentioned he's not bothered about that
kind of stuff mate my dad got me into
the the sport of martial arts I say all
the time if my dad Rong me if I come out
of this podcast right now my dad rung me
and went Tom uh I think you should sack
this m off and do something else I'd go
no worries and I'd retire right there
that's it that's it wow you trust them
so that's how much my dad means to me um
in the sport and in general as well um
like he got me into the sport he's been
at every training since all around the
world he's trained with me we've been to
loads of top top level gyms mate and I
always train with you know I train MMA
in the morning and me and my dad do
technique in the afternoon every day
every day
for 22 years that must have been hard
for him though because I know he was a
jiujitsu expert but then he's also
having to learn things to then relay
them to you I'm assuming well M he he
he's had boxing fights as a kid he's
done tie box he's done done the full
spectrum of martial arts himself so yeah
he's definitely a UK BJJ pioneer he's
one of the first black belts to come out
of the UK ever but he's done all martial
arts as well and make the guy studies
like studies the game unbelievably he's
got such a good mind and I'm so blessed
to have that guy because if it wasn't
for him I don't I wouldn't have even
made it to the UFC as I say every day
mate every single day from me being 8
years old we have practiced technique in
my dad's garage up until now that I'm 30
and we still do it we still go and Spar
in the morning and then we'll go and
break it down in the afternoon right you
need to do a bit more of this you need
to do right I've seen this video this
guy's doing this you need to practice
this put your foot there little tweet
make little tiny tweaks and make they'll
be the most boring mundane sessions
anybody has ever seen like you can't do
them sessions with 10 guys in doesn't
work no one's going to do it just for me
doing it like he'll have me stepping my
foot there stepping across and turning
it like that for 40 minutes literally
just that and if I if I turn it there
and I'm a bit off I'll you make me go
back and do it again until I've got it
right and that has been mate and a lot
of people don't see this is why why I
want to mention it and
uh every [__] day since I was 8 years
old we have been practicing stuff like
right this hand goes there boom when you
punch you got to bring it back slip off
Stu M stuff like that has been practiced
for hours upon hours upon hours and if
I've not got it right he'll be the one
telling me to do it again and if he
didn't tell me to do it again I won't be
doing it again so say he doesn't want to
stick his face in the camera he doesn't
want a load of credit for it or nothing
like that
but Mo a lot a lot of strong part of why
I do martial arts is because of him this
it it's just a complete formula for
Success when you are willing to go over
the Monday and oring details every day
but mate it's only my dad who could tell
me to do it cuz I won't be listening to
anybody else like that he knows you he
knows me and he knows when I've had
enough and we check in all the time and
yeah he knows when to push and when not
to push and that's something that I just
can't have with uh somebody else really
have you ever had like I don't know
heated moments oh plenty loads loads
absolutely any any anyone that Springs
to M where you were like [__] me that
was a a bond burnout cuz get this level
of success you have to challenge each
other you have to be pushing and like
teammates do in football match they
scream at each other don't they like
well we've had a lot lot make love
[__] L um the main ones is being like
um again going back to what we spoke
about before like me being a people
pleaser and stuff it's mainly like
people draging like come over here and
train with me we'll do a bit of this
this and this and he's like that's
[__] wrong what you doing like um
before I was training with heavyweights
he was on me like he come to a training
session like an M session that I'd be
doing in the morning there'd be no
heavyweights there and he he'd be like
Tom we get in the car after he'd be like
what you doing there he's [__] sh why
are you doing it like this I'd be like I
don't know that's that's how I do it and
then he'd be like
you need someone to test you in the gym
like you need to like he just hit me
with a reality check like that which is
something that a stranger or someone you
don't know as well can't really do like
he'd be like what you doing there he's
[__] terrible like you can't be doing
that you need to be training with heavy
weights who are going to put you in your
place when you do stuff like that which
is why we now train with heavyweights is
he the main guy in the corner or do you
have uh cuz you barely get to the corner
I don't want to [__] get some if I
don't have to cuz we never see you get a
pep talk after a first round because it
just doesn't get there
um but yeah I mean in terms of you just
being a family man as well you're
married how many kids you got three yeah
you got three kids uh what you what you
like with the husband what's you and
your M like together what's your
relationship like great she's great um
talking about my dad not liking a lime
like she hates it even more so well I
heard stories cuz it was very funny cuz
she wasn't there for the fight yeah she
wasn't there so um we had three children
I won't go into it too much cuz she gets
uncomfortable so um one of my children
has artism so um to pull that off and
get Child Care on like a week's notice
and HTS fly across the world for
multiple days is unfeasible uh so yeah
she was asleep man she she she was
asleep so I was trying to call her and
stuff but she wen't answering she was
asleep cuz of the time difference and uh
yeah I got through to her and she was
happy of course and you've mentioned uh
your child has autism I've got family
members with autism I think it was great
that you brought up because there isn't
enough awareness you see people banding
this word about in a negative way the
lack of understanding and look who no
one teaches you about autism at school
we we just sort of hear the word and we
don't really know what it means until
you actually interact with someone what
has it been like for you as a as a dad
educating yourself finding out more
about it and how have you coped with
it um first of all thanks for asking
because I always like to try and take
the opportunity to speak about it
publicly when again and it's not
something that's very easy for me to
speak about because still my my child's
only just turned four so I'm I'm in the
infancies of understanding autism and I
don't want to come out and claim that I
know St everything about a because I
don't I'm I'm happy to say that I
definitely don't um there's people
there's adults who have grown up with
autism obviously there's people now 60
70 year old people who are still caring
for the children who are in the 40s and
50s now who've got autism so I can't
preach on it too much it varies a lot it
is massive mate the spectrum is massive
the spectrum is absolutely enormous um
but what I want to try and do with my
platform
that I've got is just trying to get
awareness about kind of just because a
kid might be messing around and and
crying in public and stuff like that
mate a lot of the time the parents are
just as uncomfortable as anybody else
like me as a parent especially before we
got the
diagnosis uh my kid was acting up in
public and and crying and being
uncomfortable situations that me or you
wouldn't be uncomfortable with but um it
made him uncomfortable and we weren't
aware of it at the time and it's not
always because because the child's
naughty or they've got [__] parents the
reason why the kids acting up do you
know what I mean so I I just want people
to know about that a little bit more and
from my understanding a lot of the time
with kids it's the frustration that
they're not able to express themselves
in a way that other children can it
comes out in this way exactly and other
like other parents may be looking at
their child like oh he's misbehaving and
looking in a way of oh can not keep your
kid under control exactly that's the
that's the lack of awareness that you're
mentioning there well a few times i' I'd
be taking my kid in public and you know
it's just small stuff like they can't
explain to you especially a
three-year-old kid that they want a
specific toy in a supermarket and they
can't understand that they can't pick
that toy up and take it home with them
and you can't explain it to you try you
try and they've been yeah it's
heartbreak screaming crying pading all
the rest of it and there's been a few
times I I've had that situation in the
supermarket and some woman uh some women
have walked past me and you know give me
a dirty look and a couple of comments
here and there like oh it'd be easier if
his mom was here and it's like no it's
[__] not about that it's about the
fact that you know it's just it's just
hard mate and I just want to raise as
much like autism and awareness as I can
and done a couple of posts about on
Instagram and I'm not trying to drop
anyone in it here but I've got so many
messages of people in the public eye who
have got autistic children who I had no
idea that they had autistic children and
I just wish people in the public I would
talk about it a little bit more because
I actually the whole reason I got my son
diagnosed was because of panny mcginness
actually so I watched his documentary on
autism he has three autistic children
and it was I looked at some of them I
was like that sounds quite familiar a
lot of the stuff that a lot of the
symptoms that he's going through and
coincidentally I met him at uh we was on
a questioner sport did a questioner
sport he was the host on it and I asked
him about it and he said mate get a
diagnosis as quick as you can that's the
the main thing to do and I said we're
trying to get a diagnosis but on the NHS
luckily I'm in a financial position
where I could pay privately but mate the
waiting list now to get a diagnosis is
[__] massive like 2 three years to
even get your kid looked at it's
horrendous because there my mom works in
a school mate and there's more and more
autistic people and more and more ADHD
kids and and all that kind of stuff com
through each year and it's just massive
now it's so big to get get get a
diagnosis and the thing is mate when you
get a diagnosis that's when you can get
help so cuz as you said the spectrum is
massive mate it it can be something
that's it can go from someone not being
able to explain the feelings properly to
somebody not being able to walk and talk
ever so it's massive it's absolutely
massive and I just want to get as much
help and the word out there as possible
on on autism yeah the heartbreaking
thing from from my understanding as well
is what you've just perfectly said is
the lack of um the lack of ability right
now in public uh Health Council and all
of that to actually take care of these
kids Meanwhile we're sending trillions
to other countries who are in war and
all these problems and yet we've got
waiting lists like this for our own
children uh it's a disgrace and and um
it it's nowhere near good enough really
for what they deserve but like Well Done
M and uh I I really love what you're
doing and I think um they've obviously
got their symbol there's like this
chicksaw piece that is the symbol of
autism and it's just great that more
people are posting about this and more
people are talking about it and the
heavyweight champion of the world is a
big thank you mate thank you and I'm not
I'm I don't I'm always pretty sensitive
of kind of what I put out and what I say
and I don't want to say the wrong thing
because I'm really new to it I'm super
new to it like we've had the diagnosis
just over a year my kid is obviously
really really young at this point and I
don't know a lot of the questions that
are getting thrown my way and I don't
feel educated enough on the subject to
speak about it a lot of the time but all
I want to get out there is that there's
autistic people out there and just
please don't be so quick to judge when a
child is misbehaving that that's it
that's all I can offer right now but uh
hopefully as the years go on I'll uh
I'll get more more stuff out there that
brings us on to the final question ask
you bro how would you like to be
remembered oh that's a great question
you know I'm not the kind of guy the guy
kind of guy who likes to think too much
in the future I try not to I try and
live in the moment as much as I
can that being
said I want to be the guy
who was one
known as a fan favorite I think that's
really important someone that put on
exciting fights because ultimately
that's what this Sport's about that's
why we watch it because it's exciting
and I want I want people to look at it
and not be like I'm going to watch him
because I want to watch him lose oh he's
he's been saying this in the press
conference and he's been saying don't
interest me mate I want people to watch
and go [__] hell there's going to be
some master class on here like someone's
going to get knocked out and I want to
tune in for it that's why I want people
to watch from a martial arts perspective
so that first of all and I want to go
down as the best heavy way
ever well mate as long as you don't run
from Challengers like some Champions
that we know y I'm pretty sure that'll
happen yep that was Tom aspel on the
true Jordy podcast big love big thanks
and I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
cheers